[Music]
we come to you now with revelations
about last week's attack in london an
anonymous source provided this video it
shows quentin beck aka mysterio moments
before his death a warning you may find
this video disturbing i managed to send
the elemental back to the dimensional
riff but i don't think i'm gonna make it
off this bridge alive spiderman attacked
me for some reason he has an army
weaponized drone star technology and
he's saying he's the only one who's
gonna be the new iron man no one else
are you sure you want to commence the
drone attack there will be significant
casualties do it execute them all
the shocking video was released earlier
today
on the controversial news website the
dailybugle.net there you have it folks
conclusive proof that spider-man was
responsible for the brutal murder of
mysterio an interdimensional warrior who
gave his life to protect our planet and
who will no doubt go down in history as
the greatest superhero of all time
but that's not all folks
here's the real blockbuster brace
yourselves you might want to sit out
spider-man's real spider-man's real name
spider-man's name is peter parker
that's right folks peter parker a 17
year old high school delinquent
homicidal are you spiderman's girlfriend
are you sweating man's comfortable
spiderman
people looked up to this boy and called
him a hero well i'll tell you what i
call him public enemy number one
ever again
okay i'm so sorry but i can't see
anything with your hand in mine
okay where are we gonna go i don't know
your house no no we cannot go to my
house my dad will kill you what i
thought you said your dad really liked
me yeah well not anymore
dude
dude
dude
i'm so sorry are you okay no not really
[Music]
we should go we should go come on you
said you don't want to leave me you
should just swing me yeah okay we can
take the subway
[Music]
[Music]
are you okay yeah
come on come on okay i'm so sorry
[Music]
i just feel so dumb i didn't realize you
were miserable it was really fun that's
right you know that's why they call it a
fling
and we flung it was fun i could have
been more fun i can be fine i'll hang
out again wait what do you think
i should see what no no no no no no no
no
no
he's always coming and going it's not
oh no oh god oh no peter i don't know
what to do
oh i don't see anything this isn't what
it looks like no no this is not what it
looks like oh hey you must be up jay
you're so nice to me wait have you been
crying
we broke up
oh
oh oh
thank you i didn't know you guys broke
up i thought you were in love me no
we're talking about this i don't know i
should probably leave i think i thought
you guys were such a handsome people you
know it's really about boundaries oh let
me get into the door oh hang on let's
just go knead it at the door hey is it
true i was gonna go but not now
i'll stick around oh you're so awkward
about sex
conversation i should go but if you want
to go over it again i mean i'm what's
that sound
i mean i'm happy to rehash it if you
want to but i just don't know you take
care of your mind
i just want to talk to you about your
relationship okay
peter
what
is that is that here
i mean maybe it's not such a big deal
spider menace
governments around the world launch
investigations into the murderer known
as spider-man aka peter parker aka the
webb-headed war criminal who for years
has been terrorizing the decent citizens
of new york well now this city and the
world see him for what he truly is
new details from last week's devastating
attack in london have emerged for more
we go now to joint intelligence
headquarters thoroughness just a short
while ago confirmed that the deadly
drones used in the london attack were
designed by stark industries
federal agents opened up did you
department of damage control we have a
warrant for the arrest of peter parker
you know the fourth amendment sure
unreasonable search and seizure get in
here guys let's go
[Music]
i didn't kill quentin beck the drones
ditto the drones that are yours no well
look nick fury was there the entire time
just ask him and he can explain
everything nick fury has been off planet
for the last year
what
peter
fj oh they have nothing to do with this
sir don't say anything without a lawyer
i want a lawyer
miss jones watson jones i don't go by
watson
miss jones
why do you want a lawyer i have nothing
to hide exactly unless i'm actually
guilty of something
i'm very aware of your tactics and my
rights just answer my questions
i've seen your file
you're a smart young woman with a bright
future ahead of her
why would you risk it all by getting
involved with a vigilante like peter
parker
so sorry to keep you waiting can we get
another snack please absolutely he's
been waiting here i got you i got it
dude i'm so sorry about that
i'm not supposed to say anything to you
no no not even a thing i just have one
question when mj told you that peter was
spider-man
what's up i knew way before mj did i was
spiderman's guy in the chair oh i know
about those dude half my guys are guys
in the chat exactly you would know i
literally helped him find the vulture i
didn't know that then i helped him hack
a suit once and kind of helped him get
the space so in spider-man's illegal
vigilantism you were his main accomplice
i would like to have my words stricken
from the record with all due respect and
i mean that very insincerely unless you
have some real specific charges to throw
at us legally you can't hold us here
you should definitely lawyer out excuse
me child endangerment's a nasty rap
a boy was entrusted to you and nasa's
legal guardian essentially his mother
you not only allowed him to endanger
himself but you actually encouraged it
who does that
i want to see peter right now stark
industries was caught in the web of the
spider-man mysterio controversy today
when federal agents opened an
investigation into missing stark
technology
agents want to know exactly what was
taken at least they used a good picture
that's great
thank you
well i have some good news peter i don't
believe any of the charges against you
are going to stick but seriously oh i
knew it oh my god mr murdock thank you
that's thank you that's amazing
you're welcome perfect however mr hogan
yes the feds are actively investigating
that missing technology
i uh understand your loyalty to mr stark
and his legacy but if you were involved
if i was involved i advise securing a
lawyer i need a lawyer because i'm i'm
under investor i thought he would you
said there's no charges i could say uh
under advisement council uh i refuse to
answer the question respectfully because
the answer couldn't incriminate me
because it's
saying good fellows what was the thing
that's saying go tell us i know that's
what you think calm down let's see what
he has to say matt you're gonna need a
really good lawyer
peter you may have dodged your legal
troubles but things will get much worse
there is still a court of public opinion
[Music]
how did you just do that
i'm a really good lawyer
we're gonna need a safer place to live
[Music]
welcome
to the spiritual oasis
you like dunkin kong jr
[Music]
you